what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
loki episode 2 is out and this is going
to be
my loki episode 2 breakdown needless to
say there are going to be spoilers for
episode 2 in this video so if you are
trying to avoid those spoilers
you should click away now now there is a
ton to break down in this video
including easter eggs and a lot of
time travel rules which i'll definitely
explain in a very simple way for you and
big thank you to manscape for sponsoring
this video more on them in a bit but
first i'm going to start off with a
theory and i should add that i have not
seen past episode 2.
i only got to see the first two episodes
in advance so this isn't any spoilers
for episode 3 or beyond this is a theory
coming from me
a theory of why lady loki set off all of
the reset charges on the sacred timeline
while although i do think that was
partially her goal i do not think that
was her main goal
i actually think that this is a
distraction
at the end of episode 2 when she set off
all of the reset charges and the
timeline essentially went into madness
it looked like pretty much all the tva
agents and hunters were dispatched to
different points in time
rinslayer herself even picked up her
gear and went out
and this is what i believe was lady
loki's plan the entire time
get the tva out in the field so she can
infiltrate the tva
now why does she want to do this well we
already know that she doesn't actually
want to control the tva
and hunter c20 told us that she told
lady loki
how to find the time keepers where they
are this i believe
is lady loki's ultimate goal to find the
time keepers we also have a little bit
more proof of this when
our loki variant tells her that he wants
to take over the timekeepers she pauses
for a second when he says that
and the pause is most likely due to her
wanting to do the same thing
however she clearly thinks that she is
the superior loki and decides not to
join him because she's just gonna do it
herself
now part of me thinks that the time
keepers may not actually be real
i think one possibility is that it's
actually just kang the conqueror and
he's making it seem like the timekeepers
are real but in reality it's just him
because he is the master of time there
are more kang easter eggs coming up in
the breakdown as well but let me know
your thoughts on this theory in the
comments down below
and also let me know what you would rate
loki episode 2 give me a number between
1 and 10.
now let's get started with the breakdown
so loki episode 2 starts off
of course with the recap but then we are
led to believe that
perhaps because this is indeed a time
travel show
that we are back in renaissance times
however we are really at a renaissance
fair in wisconsin
in 1985 so not even that far back in
time the tva
immediately shows up and of course they
are noticed because they're not in
costume like everybody else now the tva
immediately picks up signal of the
variant that they are hunting
we can see the screen says variant
detected now of course we learned at the
end of episode 1 the variant that they
are searching for
is indeed loki himself or as we now know
herself they are looking for female loki
a different variant of loki but they do
not know that it's a female yet
now the way that they are able to detect
the variants is by their temporal aura
this was name dropped a couple of times
in episode 1.
we are led to believe that each variant
of loki has the same temporal aura or at
least something very similar that gives
up an energy that lets them know
they're around so they detect the loki
variant and go pursue her
now as soon as they enter the tent of
course they find out that it was a trap
the music and recording for the show
that is typically shown in that tent
comes on
and foreshadows the fact that the fight
is about to take place saying prepare
for battle
it also says that the prize is a
princess also kind of foreshadowing the
fact that the variant of loki that
they're searching for
is indeed female loki as they search for
her she takes control over hunter c20
this looks an awful lot like how the
scarlet witch uses her powers
also keep in mind that loki's mother
frigga was raised by witches and knows
witchcraft and that's how loki kind of
knows some of his tricks and it looks
like we're going to be seeing more of
the mystical
magical side of loki in this series but
notice it's not quite like how the
scarlet witch does it fema loki
actually has to touch the person with
her finger to take control
now as the fight proceeds we learn
something that makes lady loki
extremely dangerous she takes control
over hunter's c20 but she is also able
to fight herself
at the same time hunter c20 hits another
hunter with a lance and behind the
hunter pops up lady loki stabbing her in
the back
which of course is a classic loki move
not only figuratively but
literally and it looks like each variant
of loki is the same as owen wilson's
character mobius says that i've studied
your life and i've literally seen you
stab like 50 people in the back so our
loki has done it 50 times and all of
these other loki's seem to have that
same trait
now of course lady loki is simply just
walking through people here
and as she's controlling hunter c20 the
other hunter asks what she's doing and
she replies having some fun she releases
her out of her trance and then she
finishes the work herself
now this is where we discover what her
plan was the entire time trap the tva
agents and acquire one of their devices
that essentially lets them go in between
different time periods and the tva
headquarters we see that she hits the
button labeled time door and the time
door opens and she takes hunter c20 with
her and disappears through the portal
now of course we later go on to find
out that she took her to roxcart and of
course she is using her as a part of her
plan
now the last thing we hear before the
title card is the lyrics i need a hero
and then after the title card the first
thing we open up to
is loki reading mobius's magazine which
shows
us a picture of a jet ski and at the top
as you can see here it says
volume 26 number four and what i believe
this is referring to
is the loki comic issue four where on
the title it shows loki and it says
hero at last and of course loki is the
hero that the lyrics i need a hero are
referring to
now from here we learn something
extremely important
miss minutes is training loki on
everything that he needs to know to be a
tva agent
and miss minutes asks what happens when
a nexus event branches past
a redline we have seen this several
times in loki episode 1 the tva agents
are always checking their monitors to
make sure the nexus branch doesn't cross
that red line
and when a nexus event crosses the red
line we find out that that means the tva
can no longer
reset that timeline so it will become a
permanent timeline
now this will become extremely important
not only for the loki series but for the
mcu in general because remember back to
one division we had the commercial for a
nexus pill and wanda is most likely a
nexus
being in the marvel universe she has the
ability to affect
the future so the events that happened
in one division could have been nexus
events and perhaps they could have
crossed that red line we'll have to wait
and see
but moving forward remember that if the
nexus branch
crosses that red line it can no longer
be reset and according to missed minutes
that would lead to the destruction of
the timeline
and the collapse of reality as we know
it this goes back to the nexus war that
they showed us in episode one this is
what miss minutes is referring to
if we get too many timelines they will
have a multiversal war
now owen wilson comes and he adds them
to the team that is going to search for
the loki variant here we find out that
the loki variants can look very similar
or they could look
not very similar at all as we see a
giant very muscular loki that could even
be some type of a troll or an
ogre of some sort hey it's time travel
anything's possible
and they say that for the most part they
all have kind of similar powers but much
like how the variants can look
differently
we can assume that the variance power
levels are also very different as well
now loki makes a statement about him
being the superior loki which is really
just showing his
inferiority complex right now not being
able to
defeat or escape the tva realizing that
the infinity stones are powerless to the
tva
and of course dealing with the fact that
mobius said that this other loki variant
was
way more dangerous than him and i have a
feeling that this is going to be a
pretty common theme throughout the
entire series
and to add on to it hunter b15 said that
loki was a cosmic
mistake now here's a pretty important
scene that we see here
mobius tells loki he's not worried about
him betraying him because how
is that going to help him get a seat in
front of the timekeepers now remember in
the first episode mobius said that he
couldn't give loki salvation but he
could perhaps give him something greater
and here he is implying that what he
could do is get him in front of the
timekeepers
however when loki asks an audience with
the timekeepers is on the table
mobius doesn't actually tell him yes he
tells him to
keep that focus now he could be lying
here it doesn't actually seem like he
could get him an audience with the
timekeepers considering the fact that in
this episode we learned that mobius has
actually never met the timekeepers
himself
but loki knows that he can't go back to
his original timeline and the
timekeepers are the only people who
could really spare his life so mobius is
essentially using this as collateral and
motivation to get him to do a good job
and not betray the tva
now they go back to the fair and here's
where we learn something else that's
very important about time travel and
nexus events
loki asks why they can't just show up a
little bit in the past before the
variant shows
up to catch the variant mobius explains
that nexus events destabilize the time
flow so you can only show up
in real time this explains why once that
nexus event branch gets past that red
line they can no longer reset it
now loki kind of drags the tba and
mobius along with a fake story to try
and get an early audience with the
timekeepers claiming that they are in
more danger than they thought
mobius sees right through him and they
reset the timeline which according to
loki is basically disintegrating
everything
now loki screwed up that mission so it's
time for mobius to meet with judge
rinslayer about that although we are
finding out that she is more than just a
judge
she is pretty much top dog the only
person above her really is the time
keepers
it is her job to communicate with them
fulfill their orders
approve missions and mission teams and
of course be a judge as well
and in her office we see the three time
keepers as statues behind her desk and
i'm still
going to say that one of them is kang
we'll have to see how that plays out it
does appear to be that there is a head
time keeper if you notice the time
keeper in the middle is not holding
anything but the two time keepers on the
outside
are both holding hourglasses obviously
symbols of time but this could imply
that there is actually a head
time keeper now it does seem like there
is a little bit of a romance happening
here between mobius and
rinslayer rinslayer states that she has
other analysts working for her and
mobius asks would you say that i'm your
favorite now head writer michael waldron
did say that there
are going to be some romances in the
series he jokingly said that one
relationship that we'll see is between
mobius and loki
however it looks like something is
happening here with rensslayer and
mobius this is further implied by the
ring marks on
the desk mobius puts his drink down on
the desk without a coaster in which he
immediately gets chastised by rinslayer
he says the rings were already there and
she says they're all from him so this
lets us know that they have spent quite
a bit of time together whether that's
for work or for dating
now here we really learn mobius's plan
he's bringing r loki on these missions
so he can get inside of loki's head
because the more that he gets inside of
loki's head and learns about him the
more he learns about the other variant
then mobius says maybe r loki can change
but renslayer says only if the
timekeepers allow it because remember
fate is a big part of the series however
right now in the tva they are existing
outside of time and essentially existing
outside of fate
now here we learn that mobius has never
met the timekeepers
however here is something very very
interesting about this scene if you have
the closed captions on the subtitles
we see that mobius actually says right
after he says i've never met them
he says that one looks like he's got
kind of a
and then he's cut off and what i believe
he might have been going on to say here
is a familiar face that one looks like
he's got kind of a familiar face perhaps
he knows or has seen this timekeeper
before
but a different variant of the
timekeeper and this is going back to one
of my theories that one of the time
keepers is
kang the conqueror and in the comics
there are multiple versions of kang
or variants if you will so perhaps owen
wilson's mobius could have seen
a normal version of kang and this
timekeeper looks like him because it
could be him but rinslayer states that
they've never been so involved on a case
they really want the variant caught
and that of course is because they
realize what this variant is trying to
do
she is trying to essentially delete the
tva
causing multiple branches of time to
branch out causing a bunch of nexus
events to happen and essentially
creating the multiverse again which i'm
pretty sure is gonna happen but we'll
have to wait and see
and coming up is another king easter egg
but first thank you so much to manscape
for sponsoring this video
all right guys father's day is coming up
and it's time for you and your dad to
have
the talk the talk about being a
well-groomed man
and manscaped is the leader of
manscaping products by a long shot
this father's day don't give your dad a
traditional tool gift
dads always get tools but never the
right tool to help make them
a smooth man literally but manscaped can
help they just released their new tool
the lawnmower 4.0
if you want your dad or yourself to feel
like a superhero you have to groom like
a superhero just look at bro thor and
silky smooth captain america who's
getting the girl it's the one that keeps
himself well groomed looking like a boss
and for the ladies out there this is the
perfect gift for your man especially if
they need a little hint at keeping
themselves
better groomed the lawnmower 4.0 is
insane it's waterproof and cordless so
you can use it in the shower
it has ceramic blades that don't nick or
cut you eliminating all of the fear
and now's the perfect time to get one
because you can get one 20
off plus free international shipping
when you use promo code cosmic at
manscape.com
now a very interesting part happens
right before mobius leaves rinse layers
office
renslayer gives him some paperwork to
sign and gives him a pin to sign them
with he looks down at the pen
it says franklin d roosevelt high school
and side note in marvel comics franklin
d
roosevelt gave captain america his suit
and his shield and introduced him to the
press
but moving on mobius says i don't
remember this one
it's clear it's from the sacred timeline
and then he says this must be from your
analyst
on the side now remember ren slayer's
lover
in the comics is king the conqueror and
king the conqueror is confirmed to be
coming in ant-man 3 but loki is a time
travel show kang is definitely involved
in some way shape or form and
in the comics there are actually
thousands of different variations or
variants of
kang it is possible that one of these
different variants could be
an agent working for the tva now i am
aware that the timekeepers created the
tva agents but kang could have worked
his way in there somehow especially if
he
is indeed one of the actual timekeepers
basically keep your eye out for kang
during the series or perhaps even maybe
one or two of them outside of the office
loki tries to explain what happened but
mobius doesn't really care
he tells loki that he's not there for
him to learn about him he's there to
help him catch and we hear this once
again
the superior loki in which again loki
with his inferiority complex says that
i'm not sure superior is the right word
and this is where mobius tells loki
this was my plan for you to feel so
inferior
that you would want to prove that you
actually are the superior loki by
catching this other loki even if he
didn't care about the case at all
loki states that he has his own plan and
he can see that mobius has manipulated
him but mobius knows his plan and mobius
doesn't really need to manipulate loki
he straight up says i'll tell you two
things and you can believe what you want
one i see a scared little boy and i'm
trying to help him or two i'll tell you
whatever i need to tell you to capture
this other loki and you have to remember
mobius actually knows loki better than
loki knows himself
he's studied loki's entire life and even
in episode 1
mobius got him to admit things that
perhaps loki didn't know about himself
so normally loki is the one manipulating
and deceiving but it looks like in this
series loki may have his work cut out
for him with mobius for starters it
looks like he's the only one who can
actually control loki the next scene is
of mobius telling loki that he's on his
final chance and that he's going to have
to do
some work and that work is to go over
every single case file for every
different
loki variant there is and of course
there are hundreds of them but here's
the deal
loki actually does it because mobius
tells him his life depends on it now of
course
loki gets a little curious and takes
this moment where he's alone to try and
find out a little bit more about the tva
from here he tries to get some info
about the timekeepers when the timeline
was created
the end of the timeline anything he
could get his hands on but of course
the tva and its members are much smarter
than he is so
when he asks what he can see the tva
worker simply gives him his
own case file and on it we see time
violation so it does appear that
everybody pretty much knows who loki is
and that he's a variant
and of course you know it's on the back
of his jacket but here's where things
get pretty interesting and somewhat
confusing i've had a lot of people ask
me already to
explain this scene and i'm going to
right now loki starts to go over some
case files and he finds the destruction
of asgard from ragnarok
they say it's a class 7 apocalypse and
they go on to say that the rox card
apocalypse is a class
10 which makes you wonder what the snap
was
we're gonna go ahead and say it was a
class 3000 apocalypse loki gets
teary-eyed because he notices that it
was the destruction of his entire
civilization and there actually is a
pretty cool easter egg here where it
says
revengers which of course was the name
of the team that consisted of thor
the hulk valkyrie and loki himself now
from here things start to get
very very important but loki doesn't
exactly do a very good job with his
metaphor in describing the situation
so i'm going to basically do my best to
put it in plain and simple terms
in this report of the apocalypse of
ragnarok loki sees a line that says no
variants energy detected this is where
he sort of has the epiphany that this is
where the other loki could be hiding and
here's the reasoning why
right before an apocalypse happens
nothing really matters
right before it happens why because
everything is going to basically become
extinct and die
get blown up get drowned in water
whatever it may be it doesn't matter
because the apocalypse is going to
happen
you could go into the apocalypse and
kill a bunch of people and it doesn't
matter because they were going to die
anyways
so you wouldn't create a branch timeline
because it doesn't matter
so that is where the loki is hiding why
because
no variance energy could be detected
because no branch timeline would be
created
so loki has discovered that the variant
is using apocalypses as a way to kind of
shadow herself and not be detected by
the tva
so they test the theory they go to
pompeii and loki
literally yells we are from the future
we are the time variants authority and
nothing happens a new branch timeline is
not created and there is zero variance
energy detected
proving his theory correct we then have
a very important scene that essentially
explains
the fate of the mcu mobius basically
says that yes the timekeepers write the
past the present and the future
he says that they are currently writing
the future and once they're done
essentially the tva can go away because
there will be no more chaos
everything will have to be written and
will be in order essentially the
timekeepers will have written
everybody's fate
and i'm guessing this is why lady loki
has a big problem with the tva and the
timekeepers
so then from here owen wilson realizes
that the female
loki variant gave the little kid from
the first episode kablooey gum
they used this to figure out which
natural disaster female loki is hiding
in since kablooey was only sold on earth
from 2047 to
2051. and that's how they trace her
location to the rox cart apocalypse
now when they show up it's raining and
notice how loki actually used his magic
to make himself dry
this is pretty revealing he has his
magic when he is
outside of the tva however mobius
explained in this episode that he's not
really afraid of loki because he knows
that the tba can just catch him however
that doesn't really work out for them
though at the end of this episode
hunter b15 says that loki has to go with
her and of course they end up stumbling
on
loki the other loki this loki who
apparently wants to be called randy can
seemingly mind control people
pretty easily she takes over b15 and
loki meets
lady loki and lady loki makes it pretty
clear that she is the superior one she
says
if anything you are me and based off of
the way that she's handled everything so
far
i'm gonna say that's correct now loki
would go on to tell us that what she is
doing
is an enchantment and i know a lot of
people are thinking that this could
actually be enchantress and i don't
believe that to be the case i do believe
it is
lady loki we have seen her in the comics
and i think that's who she is for sure
now arloki tells lady loki that he's not
working for the tva
they're working for him and she seems to
think that he's pretty foolish for
thinking that and then she switches
bodies she switches from hunter b15
to another person and something to
notice here is that loki is genuinely
concerned if b15 is going to be all
right he immediately goes to her side to
see if she's still alive
but of course loki has to follow female
loki because he has to figure out what
she's trying to do
however he makes a proposition to her
first he essentially reveals that he's
been using the tva to get to her
his true plan is to overthrow the
timekeepers and he needs a lieutenant
which of course is her
loki also reveals that in the
renaissance fair he was actually
stalling so fema loki could come in and
kill the tva members or at least give
her time to do her thing as he says he
kept them vulnerable for
some time so loki in true fashion has
been playing the tva pretty much the
whole time or at least that's what he
wants
her to think because i do believe that a
part of him actually does want to help
the tva so he can get an audience with
the timekeepers and essentially save his
own life
however she denies him she also says
that her name is randy but that was the
name of the worker that she possessed so
that's not her real name meanwhile
mobius and the other tba hunters find
c20 and she seems to be very very scared
repeating
it's real it's real now what is real
well we
really have no idea i'm definitely going
to speculate but let's leave that for
another video
she does reveal however that she gave it
away she gave away how to find the time
keepers where they are which is very
interesting to me that a hunter tva
agent would know
where and how to find the timekeepers
when mobius hasn't even met them himself
but this is something that'll have to
unfold for us to find out now after
possessing another
huge body lady loki finally reveals
herself
which i thought was an insanely cool
moment and definitely the highlight of
the episode now of course she was really
just stalling the entire time
she set a bunch of reset charges that
are about to go off and from the looks
of it she set up around
30 of the reset charges now right before
they go off
she opens up time doors and sends them
away presumably she sends these to parts
of the sacred timeline
the reasoning to this is because the
sacred timeline begins to have
a lot of different branches a lot of
different nexus events in various
different points of time
and as i mentioned in my theory in the
beginning of the video i think she did
this intentionally to cause chaos to get
the tva to kind of
come out of the headquarters now for
somebody who claims to not
really want anything to do with loki she
does leave the time door
open for him it's open for a while
enough for him to escape the clenches of
mobius and b15 and notice how it closes
right as he goes through it like she was
waiting for him
on the other side now we've seen the
previews for where they go they go to an
apocalyptic location
it looks like there's a moon shattered
in the background perhaps this could be
titan we know thanos shattered and threw
part of a moon at the avengers so this
could be titan after that battle
also we see on the tva screen where
nexus location branches are being set
off
and we see actually a few known
locations from the mcu
one location is ego otherwise known as
star lord's father but also a planet
another planet we see here is titan
thanos's home planet and where the
eternals used to live
some of them at least other locations
are new york tokyo japan
and hala we do also see that vormir
where the soul stone was and
asgard are two of the locations as well
and here one of the tva
agents does confirm that she did in fact
bomb the sacred timeline so those time
door portals sent the reset charges to
different points
in the sacred timeline pretty much all
of the tva is dispatched presumably to
all of these different branches created
and of course in true loki fashion
arloki gets away
now here are my final thoughts on this
episode one i don't actually believe
that lady loki is going to be the main
villain i think that there's somebody
else coming and i also don't think that
our loki
is bad if you met a different version of
yourself that was seemingly smarter than
you
and clearly had a bigger plan than you
had you'd definitely want to follow that
version and see what they're about
where they're from what their story is
and what their plan is so i don't think
loki is totally bad and totally
betraying the tva
and i don't think that fema loki will be
the main villain i do think kang is
going to show up at one point in time
but my absolute final thought
is that we better see mobius writing a
jetski
saying wow by the end of the series and
i am dead serious about that
but overall i super enjoyed episode two
let me know what you thought about it in
the comments down below let me know what
you would rate it give me a number
between 1 and 10.
of course don't forget to subscribe so
you can stay up to date on all things
related to loki and the mcu
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof